[Music]
and in more than meets the hi news ha
submitted by California summers a model
defense her love with her boyfriend who
most people think it'd only be a sugar
daddy oh my god is he like 89 you gotta
be all in fact or one of the other dude
oh yeah I seen this this is pretty funny
yeah so this model here she is an adult
kind of model and she just over 18 which
is very good she's also a cam girl she's
26 years old and she used to be a sugar
baby yeah at one point yeah but this
time it's real I've never heard the term
sugar baby
a fairy sugar daddy what's a super the
one that's with the sugar daddy they
call them sugar babies yeah okay never
knew that was not all of them whole and
some of them just like so they say yeah
yeah some of them are just there for the
dates and someone was just getting paid
just to hang out yeah cuz some dudes are
just so lonely and they'll just give
them money to be like hey hang out with
me so they say alright like sometimes
they won't even meet face-to-face and
they just want someone in like text or
talk to them phone really yeah anyway oh
oh she so her name is Sarah and she has
been with her boyfriend Mason who's 54
years old for about 7 months now and
this is what they look like oh that guy
looks like a shaved lion but look at
that watch though that's a ap he's got
to have money yeah so he used to be a
child actor so he's probably getting
some residual that's like in the 70s he
came out in a lot of commercials and he
came out in certain talk shows and stuff
I was like Annie Milonakis you get the
haircut yeah he has the exact same
haircut you seen it no but I can tell
exactly when he was a kid the seventies
hair yeah so he also he how they get
around in New York City you got
Pomeranian puppy in the basket he looks
like a wooden which in every picture
he's look too hungover this is a
straight-up a big the child star of
course he's hungover what what show is
it um so he's did a lot of commercials
oh I think he's done he's been on like
certain talk shows from the 70s he don't
look rich that don't look like a life of
luxury so maybe she really is with him
for him cuz he did know otherwise he
wasn't for the money yeah he wasn't
really well gonna talk about no so she
looks like he could have been oh I'm
sorry
he was a boy Luba Oh what so he would
just do a lot of commercial work he's on
the cover of TV Guide he was ugly at
every phase of his life he's been doing
it yeah you're three years old there the
whole time I was playing the game is it
real or is it fake because man this
story gets they get pretty detailed on
there's more he looks like a grown man
every 41 there he looks the same age I
mean ask 41 he looks for yeah this is so
weird
does he have something he just ugly or
does he have some faces whoa with his
hair cut like that if he wasn't an opal
nobody should fire his agent yeah like
he's just I think he has something like
some kind of coma zone stuff that we
don't know like the Andy Milonakis thing
yeah maybe
yeah but Andy just looks like a kid this
guy looks like a like it's like Benjamin
Button disease or something yeah like
his face is a picture but it didn't
fully develop it's just they don't
mention me a page no no yeah okay cuz if
he's just ugly I don't feel combined
with talent and a unique look that's all
right he's just ugly though because man
if he had something
Kant downs or something I'll be like oh
[ __ ] I [ __ ] up yeah Mason Reese yeah
so how is she getting back last night
people are getting that on social media
or something yeah so whenever they'll
post photos or she'll post photos
together would be like no [ __ ] way
like how much is he paying you to be
with him and all this doesn't look like
has anybody she's just like she's like
no like I'm really happy with him I
don't need to be with him for his money
like there's 20 guys I could be my sure
daddy but I'm with him because I like
him it might be really cool thing like
her type is like really old guys she
likes the like white hair and like the
ring perfect sugar baby yeah amazing
made to hoe
what are you guys talking about no this
is what I can give you a little credence
to this I can understand this
being a big dude I'm still a big do but
I used to be a lot bigger guys like 210
pounds bigger whenever I wore like 210
on top of what you are yeah it's your
pitch but yeah but the thing is is that
when people never think a fact I can get
a good-looking girl so why would you
girls people will be like oh you must be
paying her money house broke his [ __ ]
like I was like no not because there's
troubles yeah that was me whoa oh I love
that you have a kool-aid man no why oh
[ __ ] well damn that guy's not fat or he
he just looks like no one would like
them songs but I'll be saying when I was
that baby and I'd be with a chick people
be like oh you must mean it like mom I'm
just nice and I know I knew plenty of
like big dudes that has you know pretty
girlfriends and stuff so it's not really
the big factor I think it's like not
only is he big but he looks sloppy he
looks like crazy old and but then there
are you know women out there with fetish
we definitely have the fetish when
you're with this with a pretty gal
though and you looked like that in the
picture
you also set the difficulty level too
high to make people look at you going
going how did he get with that
got it I understood it yeah because
you're dressed like the kool-aid man
right people are already going like
that's pretty crazy because if you were
big but then you also like we're as food
or whatever and then you're that's like
oh yeah he's probably charming or
whatever right
and in this case it doesn't help that
she was a cam girl she was a sugar baby
she's from that war she usually dresses
really skimpy - yes it was like all that
fits that profile of a girl that kind of
comes in and black widows a dude you
know and I have another theory as well
as why he might have been able to get
hurt a lot of times been really
attractive women try to date really
attractive guys they're just as much of
[ __ ] as much as like you know what I
mean so you dealing we go and [ __ ]
laughs like most fat guys but nice as
hell like you know I'm saying like
you're a safety net yeah like you don't
like I don't know if it like I got
taught from other fat ladies when I was
coming up there was just like don't beat
a fat funky [ __ ] so don't like do you
always got to keep good hygiene but
there was you know I'm saying don't be
that guy he was like it just always just
be nice like you know I'm saying you'll
be surprised how far that get you know
I've been able to knock some bad ones
way bigger than this cuz I think I think
every woman wants to try it out at least
wants they want a big guy to put his
stomach on their back when they're
having sex no doubt yeah that's when you
live in life maybe I'm inaudible that
gets written about in fantasy novels a
lot in the romantic and never once been
like never there is a type of women out
there and I call it the nurse factor
where they're super what's the word
nurturing to the point where they want
to get the most ugliest damaged thing
and like feel so they get big it
connected to that like it's a power
thing they want to be like that is like
look at me look what I did to this a lot
of relationship is going wrong because
people go into a being like oh I'm gonna
fix this is my Proclamation - yeah help
no like they're like the most important
thing that's ever happened to this guy
well you you're in a different situation
because obviously you you don't have the
nurse factor you have that I can't say
no factor is my problem yeah
that's my problem but I think there are
a few people that we all know that has
the nurse factor yeah who so see the
piece you might have that with him maybe
but when I read this story though what
was crazy is that so they basically met
at like a convention or some [ __ ] like
that
what was it so initially is that they
they had a mutual friend that that
person was talking to her about Oh about
the child actor and being a child actor
so she friended him on Facebook and
started damn damning him so it first
started through Facebook and that's
already weird yeah yeah so then cuz why
would you want to hit him up if you've
never seen him so you're not attracted
to him she was like oh a child actor I
had that bag maybe but no she said she
thought she looked him up hmm
and then that's when she saw him and
then but why would you look him up that
mean that that tells me easy target well
my maybe maybe the person that was
talked about uh spoke highly about okay
I'll give it like all usually cool dude
and this is nothing y'all ain't thinking
about cuz I probably don't look at fact
I like this maybe he's [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of her
yeah true maybe he dropped it off yeah
yeah I don't even think it's a fat thing
though to me it's just like there's so
many things on top of the fat thing like
the age difference and he's in a
wheelchair and he's like oh that was
that's a mobility scooter yeah so he
dresses sloppy
no that's oh yeah so he uses this as his
mode of transportation instead of taking
the taxi or the subway when I always
likes the bigger thing about this is
they just look like they have nothing in
common yeah that's what are y'all doing
on dates yeah well well going back to
the store the first day that they met
they click because they talked for like
three hours and and they just had the
longest make-out session ever yeah see
it I can say that to like that's nothing
that you can do if you're if you're fat
do like if you have multiple
conversations with a woman and can show
her your personality and then she don't
[ __ ] with you just because you're fat
then she'll look like she's shallow so
maybe he showed her himself of who he
truly was like
really really good guys this is the
shrink story yep this is the truth
I feel like though that is true like
women are just way more forgiving it
seems like than men when it comes to
looks well dude scientifically guys put
looks ahead of ya other categories like
if it's if the guys is like top three
for the girls it's like top ten yeah
look at our group like the girls look
way hotter than all the guys yeah for
sure
dude like friends like all of our
girlfriends and wives and stuff like I'm
just like damn and you get us and it's
like how the [ __ ] does this work
everyone asks all the time
told miles popular questions but yes so
they like there's a girl like maybe love
is just blind maybe they just get each
other
cannot me sometimes you can date like
his you know she's attractive you know
I'm saying he's not that you know
attractive but I'm dad it really
attractive women never just [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah so sometimes this is like
yeah you like yes you look good but I
don't just a good person because a lot
of pretty people are ugly on the inside
looks burn out quick man go were you
that big baby 2015 okay so have you been
with your same chick since then nah man
I'm moving around mm yeah like I got
married like in 2015 to July 7th of 2015
oh you remember your eighty seven day
wedding day guy all the guys that are
hated alike oh man I wanted to [ __ ] her
that's why they're saying they should
she was a cam girl yeah and so he was
like yeah I mean it makes her happy I
just watch TV when she's camming like no
big deal and he also says like she's
never once asked him for a single penny
so he's convinced Wow it's maybe he
provided months or something like this
is too tidy for me man it's too neat and
tidy a story like I feel like he's just
like Dan this is dope and she has some
daddy issues yeah there's something yeah
yeah I see that she's getting something
like home
or some kind of like stability from this
dude but yeah she's getting something
out of it maybe it's not money I'm
riding for dude I'm saying he blowing
her back out on a nightly basis right
yeah I think you're probably right
I mean what if done so really what's
happening whatever used to be right she
has no idea how to deal with it yeah
[Music]